georges lemoine vous n'allez pas une
chatte et alenty portrait chinois
si vous étiez une injure grospatapouf
way groupe à tous que je milite pour le
retour des des insultes
inoffensif et une simple oui voilà c'est
ça par exemple si vous voulez y et
mazouté si vous me dites je ne supporte
pas grospatapouf y aller avec toute la
haine que vous pouvez essayer pour voir
grospatapouf voilà vous n'êtes pas
crédible j'ai pas envie de vous taper
non c'est le retour à la paix si vous
étiez une maladie une maladie l'acné
l'acné parce que cela vient beaucoup
quand vous étiez petit énormément elle
disons qu'à une époque si regardez bien
entre mes boutons on peut voir mes yeux
a constitué un petit peu le niveau
si vous étiez un accident un accident je
serai le début d'une liaison ce que je
suis un très très mauvais dragueur donc
à chaque fois le début c'est un accident
c'est une perversion enregistrer les
chiffres et des lettres et faire des
compiles
vous étiez vulgaire la vie de couple
évidemment cela veut dire que tout le
monde peut vivre un vis à vis le bon mot
comme beaucoup d'humoristes ça m'arrive
de dire le contraire de ce que je pense
pour faire un bon bah ouais donc c'est
une vraie humble avis une trahison ne
plus être supporters du paris
saint-germain jusque quand les
supporters ces avis et en ce moment faut
avoir du mérite pour un supporter du
paris saint germain
donc j'ai numérique
si vous étiez une arme le cynisme au
cynisme parce que c'est un état d'esprit
qui permet de relativiser beaucoup de
choses way un supplice il serait dire
pauvre résister une cicatrice avec
quelque chose dont je me suis parmi ces
à la fin des forbans passé restés
ouverts et j'ai du mal à bien
franchement le départ de bébert si vous
étiez un poison la kryptonite la culte
au knicks et c'est le poison enfin c'est
la pierre qui fait du mal à superman
parce que quand j'étais petit je voulais
être super héros d'ailleurs je vous dis
à l'impôt l'autographe je trouve que
c'est l'impôt le plus sympathique que
j'ai payé depuis que je passe à la
télévision et j'ai beaucoup de mal à
gérer ça parce que j'ai toujours
impression qu'on se fout de ma gueule
pourquoi les gens me demandent un
autographe et il enchaînera il ya deux
attitudes d'ailleurs j'ai pas si vous
avez remarqué mais il ya des gens qui ne
demandent un autographe dit mais c'est
pour qui pour marquer de choses fait
passer pour moi
où il ya celui qui assume pas qui dit
ouais tu peux me donner un autographe
c'est pas pour moi c'est pour ma petite
soeur ah ouais c'est pas les
commentateurs christophe
vous étiez une panne à la page blanche
ouais ça qui me fait le plus peur est un
dictateur
le pèse personne une infirmité la
renault kangoo
ça rendrait rieux c'est très bon un
microbe gérard miller souvent cette
interview on l'a joué à des écrivains
des intellos qui nous font des réponses
si vous étiez une plaie une plaie la
playstation
ouais c'est mon côté je nourris donc j'y
vais tranquille pour l'émission une
humiliation faire la vaisselle
un terroriste un publicitaire si j'étais
mort
une pendaison avec un grille pain parce
que si vous calculez bien votre coup
quand les gens vous découvre il ya des
choses qui leur sont à la gueule
comme éviter
le chantage
mais seulement